hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe schon lange nichts mehr
mit äpfeln gemacht deswegen die zeit ein
leckeres abzug rezept und zwar esse ich
ganz gerne apfel küchlein und ich mache
trotz der relativ kleine menge für
moritz wäre und mich und auch für
küchlein kann man auf verschiedene
weisen herstellen
entweder als apfelringe die man in den
teig kommt und aus wachs oder man
schneidet die äpfel klein oder man macht
als großen pfannkuchen und ich werde auf
jeden fall heute die variante machen wo
man eben die äpfel klein stückl muss und
einfach mit in den teig rhein gibt und
ich zeige euch einfach mal kurz die
zutaten
ich habe hier 50 milliliter milch 140
gramm zucker 60 gramm mehl eine prise
salz
ich bin ein bisschen vanille extrakt bei
äpfel sind ungefähr 300 gramm und die
schale einer bio zitrone und so erst
scheele ich jetzt schon mal die äpfel
dann entferne ich jetzt das kerngehäuse
mache ich jetzt hier mit so einem apfel
kerngehäuse entfernen
jetzt werden die äpfel noch fein
gewürfelt das mache ich jetzt hier eben
alligator aber könnte natürlich auch
einfach besser machen
hmm
ist nämlich schon mal die bio zitrone
und treibt so ein bisschen die schale ab
die mache ich jetzt gerne mit rein weil
ich einfach zitronenschale als aroma
sehr gern mag und ich finde es passt
halt auch gut zum apfel deswegen
klammerte da ruhig mit benutzten und mit
rein geben und dann nehme ich auch
direkt in kraft und teufel so ein paar
tröpfchen über die äpfel roboter mit
jetzt nicht braun werden während ich den
teig herstellen
so die halbe zitrone etwa
das dann kurz verrühren
und jetzt kann ich hier den teig
herstellen dafür kommt jetzt das in die
schüssel dann das mehl und die milch
einfach alle konnten brachte auch keine
küchenmaschine bis sie in salz und ein
bisschen vanille war fast schon zu viel
und jetzt ganz kurz mit dem schneebesen
verrühren
kommen die apple mit rein
und dann einfach nur noch kurz verrühren
und ich mache es gerne auf diese weise
denn wenn man jetzt die äpfel in ringe
schneiden und die dann in den teig rein
punkt finde ich hat man halt immer zum
schluss entweder äpfel übrig oder teig
übrig dann muss man wieder bisschen zeit
machen und da hat man immer zum schluss
irgendwas übrig deswegen mache ich das
ganz gerne so ich möchte diese weniger
apfel natürlich nehmen können oder weil
kleinere dass ich den teig ganz kurz
stehen während ich sauber machen und
richtung eine pfanne
ich habe jetzt bei mir noch ein bisschen
mehl zucker und milch dazu gegeben denn
die zweite waren doch etwas zu groß das
heißt wenn euch das auch passiert können
wir einfach noch ein bisserl von den
zutaten mit rein geben dass eben die
äpfel schön mit dem teig umhüllt sind
also so wie jetzt hier und jetzt lasse
ich hier bereits eine pfanne erhitzen
und ganz schon mal in der zwischenzeit
ein bisschen zimt zucker machen und um
zu machen braucht die not und zucker da
gebe ich jetzt ein teelöffel zimt in so
eine kleine schüssel
je nachdem wie viel zum tier eben mögt
und etwas zucker das sind so etwa drei
esslöffel und am einfachsten ist wenn
ihr den deckel zu macht und so ein
bisschen schüttelt den zimt zucker
passte eben einfach am besten mit dazu
mittlerweile ist die pfanne jetzt auch
heiß und jetzt könnt ihr entweder mit
ihnen butterschmalz auspacken mache ich
auch ganz gerne habe ich jetzt noch
nicht da oder ihr nehmt einfach etwas
sonnenblumenöl
das ist nämlich geschmacksneutral und es
kann man das super benutzen
jetzt etwa zwei esslöffel öl in die
pfanne dann am besten mit so einem
silikon pinsel kurz verteilen hatte ich
kurz bis es warm wird
jetzt können wir zum beispiel mit hilfe
von so einem ice portionierer oder einer
schöpfkelle oder einem esslöffel kleine
teig portionen hier in die pfanne geben
dann sind sie auch gleichmäßig groß und
die backe ich dann jetzt von beiden
seiten groß ich denke es dauert etwa
zwei bis drei minuten pro seite
die hitze habe ich jetzt auf mittlere
hitze gestellten mittel bis hoch also
nicht so heiß
nach 23 minuten sind sie dann schön
goldbraun und ich kann sie wenden und
einfach nur mal von der zweiten seite
ausbacken
die apfelküchle sind ausgebacken weiß
ich aber richtig drauf das zu probieren
ja der murat mag eigentlich nichts
warmes und süßes zugleich aber ich denke
es schmeckt im topf ist weil macht
sachen die man einfach ich mag also ist
schwarz aber warm und süß das geht gar
nicht aus hessisch vanilleeis mit heißen
himbeeren schaefer kalk meter weit
aber das ist halt mit dabei denn ich
habe jetzt ab küche mit etwas zimt
zucker bestreut und wer möchte gibt
einfach noch ein klecks schmand oder
crème fraiche mit dazu berühre ich nur
jetzt kurz den mache ich jetzt neben
dran weil ich weiß nicht ob du lust dazu
mag oder nicht
ich glaube nur nicht so gewesen 20
cremig und lecker sein schwanz
superlecker als darf nur einmal
probieren wenn er die übrigens etwas
lockerer haben wollt könnt ihr einfach
so eine prise backpulver mit rein geben
und dann werden sie auch etwas lockerer
die stunde der wahrheit mourad macht
wirklich kein milchreis der mag nichts
warmes nichts süßes mal gucken wie gut
wir wirklich gut ich glaube die normale
mensch ist was schönes
okay aber für dich ist nichts das ich
halte das was süß okay ich würde
vielleicht kalt essen oder lassen lang
lexus abgenommen dass ich es ist warm zu
raum hat ist es ist jetzt noch das ist
weg ich na ja das würde ich eine absage
weil dadurch majestic hinter norden auch
frisch mit dem kumpel was ja stimmt mit
eis kann es ganz gut schmecken oder mit
marmelade mit flauem und muss kann ist
mir richtig lecker vorstellen oder mit
einer vanillesoße mehr warme oder eine
kalte auf jeden fall ist es für mich so
ein dass er eigentlich ich es gerne als
nachtisch aber ich weiß noch aus meiner
kindheit ich war so oft beim einer
schulfreundin und da gab es diese april
küchlein auch als hauptgericht nach der
schule also es fand ich war auch total
das highlight dann immer zu ihr zu gehen
und dann bei der oma das zu essen
warst du eine kindheit ja ich habe angst
ich hab die arbeit
ich weiß aber auch mal ist die auch ganz
gern zu einer kartoffelsuppe mit dazu
und zwar kartoffeln super ist deftig und
dann gibt es eben was süßes mit dazu
passen apfelküchle eben mit dazu oder
zum beispiel auch im rahmen kuchen
ich weiß dass es bei murat netz geht er
mag nämlich nicht salziges und süßes
gemeinsam aber ich find's super lecker
vor allem ist man das hier in der region
halt einfach so bei den bauarbeitern
schwaben bestimmt auch neuesten zu naja
ich diskutiere das jetzt noch mit dem
rad schnell aus ihr dürft das rezept
gerne nachmachen auf 6 - blog.de steht
noch mal und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder biss dann sage nur aussagen
machte